en square como una zona libre de armas
eso es lo que dicen los carteles que
están colgando las autoridades gracias a
una ley estatal que entra en vigor el
jueves una respuesta del estado a la
declaración de la corte suprema que
indicó que los estadounidenses tenían el
derecho constitucional a portar armas
y que más puede hacer el tribunal
supremo para poner en peligro la
seguridad en nuestras calles en
respuesta tuvimos que elaborar una lista
de lugares sensibles donde las armas
están prohibidas estos lugares sensibles
incluyen escuelas colegios guarderías
bibliotecas restaurantes que sirven
alcohol
la medida aplica también para parques
centros religiosos entre otros
en la jce enganchar los portadores de
armas con licencia y otras personas no
pueden entrar con un arma a menos que la
ley lo autorice específicamente no
pueden decirme que esto no es una
sensación surrealista en nuestra ciudad
tener que poner estos carteles son más
libres de armas
web post enisa además de esta
restricción el 4 de septiembre entrará
en vigor una nueva ley que eleva a 21
años la edad para comprar armas
semiautomáticas incluirá que los
peticionarios hagan un curso para
obtener los permisos de compra y se les
pedirá que muestren sus redes sociales
de los últimos tres años para hacer una
revisión de carácter y conducta estas
nuevas medidas han causado impugnaciones
a los tribunales por parte de los
propietarios de armas que dicen que se
les limitan indebidamente sus derechos
constitucionales
nueva york- hace parte de los seis
estados que tenían disposiciones legales
sobre las armas y que tras la decisión
del tribunal supremo han quedado
invalidadas